fire kills whites you told me what
breathes fire hey youtubers
congratulations for surviving comic-con
now we got to freak out about episode
two just careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen it yet I was surprised by
how many times they referenced Aegon's
conquest and Robert's rebellion they
keep doing that in each the episode so
it's probably going to keep happening to
where they like in events that are
happening at present-day this very same
thing played out before but if you're
new to the channel I'm doing Game of
Thrones videos all season be sure to
subscribe to get everything and there is
a giveaway I'll explain at the end of
the video but starting with number 10
Stormborn so like they actually narrated
in the early part of the episode
Daenerys was born during the end of
Robert's rebellion while a great storm
was raging over Dragonstone the most
depressing sight ever you come to your
ancestral home and it's the exact
opposite whether from a sunny marine but
the interesting thing is it goes beyond
that there are a lot more parallels
because during the night of that storm
of her birth the Targaryen fleet was
being smashed in the eastern sea so just
like at the end of this episode the
Greyjoy fleet that they had got smashed
by Euron's fleet so it's almost an exact
repeat of the events of that night but I
love how Daenerys starts to turn on her
small council a little bit it's just her
way of letting them know that she has
her eyes on them she doesn't completely
trust them even though she believes that
they'll be loyal I'll burn you alive
otherwise I love the nice hat tip for
the Mad King burning Rickard stark which
they later referred to during the Jon
Snow's storyline remember what happened
when our grandfather went to meet the
Targaryen king they're still referring
to Jon Snow as a stark because they
don't know his heritage yet it we'll
talk about this again in a second but he
also said that sonses the only stark in
Winterfell like we know brans gonna show
up eventually too so there was a lot of
eye winking in this episode for things
that we know they're setting up but that
the characters don't know yet the Queen
of thorns also had a really nice moment
with Daenerys where she's like you're
not a sheep like the rest of the Lords
of Westeros are you you're a dragon so
maybe you don't always listen to Tyrion
so I think what she's just trying to
tell Daenerys is not to use too much
restraint Margery was a wonderful person
and now she's a pile of ashes so we'll
see what happens when they actually go
up against the Lannister army I cannot
wait to see what Tyrion does when
they're facing Jaime and
open battle because we haven't got to
that yet but number nine
Melisandre shows up speaking high
Valyrian explaining the prophecy of the
prince who was promised and I love myths
and eyes tip actually you know it's a
gender-neutral prophecy which theory
crafters like I've said on my channel
pretty much anybody who's ever put a
game of Thrones prince who has promised
theory on the Internet has pointed out
the fact that it could be a man could be
a woman based on the way the prophecy
should be interpreted the way high
Valyrian intends it to be but she's just
explaining to Daenerys who Jon Snow is
why he's so important let him come and
tell you what he's seen you need to form
an alliance
but even though Tyrion vouches for him
which I did like like I trust him I went
to the wall with him I think the reason
why they added that line where Daenerys
is like I'm going to make him bend the
knee is because they don't want it to
seem too easy Daenerys is sort of
looking at her small council with where
he eyes she's also doing the same thing
with Jon Snow so it's not like they're
gonna all start hugging on site and
embrace John is the secret Targaryen
they still don't know anything about his
heritage Daenerys has barely just
learned anything about the White Walkers
so number eight down in King's Landing
is Tyrion predicts exactly Cersei takes
a very xenophobic approach and trying to
turn the tyrell bannermen to her side
they're going to come in with their
Dothraki hordes burn pillage everything
and raze it to the ground we need to
unite against them so Jamie dangles the
idea of becoming warden of the south in
place of the Tyrells once they defeat
their army the really cool thing about
this interaction though the more fun
scene was when Jamie started talking to
them because he's like are you Rickard
Tarly and all of a sudden everyone's
like ah triggered again another Rickard
stark name-drop special meaning for
Jamie because he was there to witness
Rickard burning when the Mad King set
him on fire and then it gets even better
because randyll Tarly throws the fact
that Jamie's a Kingslayer in his face
the Tarly name means something we don't
stab people in the back which is the
Kingslayer reference and we don't slit
people's throats when we've invited them
to dinner for a wedding which of course
is a hat tip for the red wedding which
the Lannisters engineered so they want
to show you that he has principles like
he's not a completely evil person it'll
be interesting to see what ends up
happening when Samwell
that he's fighting for the opposition
speaking of which cut to the Citadel
number seven we finally get into the
surge or a plot line I love the way the
Ebro s-- is reacting to all this like
nope he's incurable can't do anything
about it
the archmaester they thought of some
secret techniques for deterring
greyscale what happened to him he died
of greyscale so there's nothing you can
do about it so of course Samwell isn't
gonna listen to that he uses the
archmaester special techniques and
basically just cuts the greyscale off
and then is going to treat it it's going
to involve some dragonglass
treatment so we haven't quite got to
that they'll follow up with it next week
like you've done the first part now you
need to prevent it from coming back in
the future
the really extra bits that I loved about
these scenes though is that ebro's looks
at Jorah sword looks at him and says
I'll give you one more night in case
there's something you want to do so he's
basically telling Jorah I'm gonna give
you time to go out honorably so before
Samwell comes in to cure him he looks at
the sword again as he's writing that
letter to Daenerys like he's actually
contemplating maybe I go out this way
rather than die slowly but I think of
course we know that he's going to be
cured it's just gonna be incredibly
painful and what about that transition
from like the pus and his wound to the
man's supo at the end of the crossroads
it's almost like Dan and Dave are trying
to be as gross as they can this year
they have the poop montage in episode 1
they have the pus montage in episode 2
and you may have spotted that one of the
books that he was giving to Sam well
because he's giving him all these
history books he's writing a history of
Robert's rebellion remember there's
information that we need to know on the
show we need to know what happened
between Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna
stark that's probably inside that book
just a little plot bomb that they
planted now that'll explode in a later
episode but of course number 6 hot pie
is back and explains to Aria what
happened in the north during season 6 oh
the Bolton's they're dead Jon Snow your
brother he's king of the north and she
immediately almost craps her pants and
turns around and goes home probably the
funniest part in the episode was when he
starts going on and on about the night
lady did she ever find you and then he
starts talking about baking the butter
into the pies which is the same speech
that he bored Brienne to death with when
he ran into
the secret is is that you gotta use
butter not everybody does that
in REO replies with I've been baking
some pies too didn't use butter talking
about the Frey pies that she's been
cooking and we finally get this touching
Nymeria reunion and even though it's
bittersweet I actually think it ends on
a hopeful note because Aria recognizes
that Nymeria is better off doing what
she's doing now being in the wild that's
not you anymore who is a girl a girl is
no one no I'm Arya Stark of Winterfell
so Arya is still Arya Stark of
Winterfell
but Nymeria is not of Winterfell anymore
but she still recognized Arya and they
have that moment so if they were to run
into each other again in the future she
would probably nod to her and then just
run off on her way again but the really
cool thing is if they ever choose to
bring them back and I don't know that
they will because they're kind of
expensive they could always bring them
back in season eight I'm not expecting
super-pac to come back during season
seven is is they are a hardcore weapon
one direwolf by themselves as badass but
a direwolf leading a giant Wolf Pack is
awesome so number five this was so
awesome
Qyburn takes Cersei down into the crypts
beneath the Red Keep and shows her all
the Targaryen dead dragon skulls and
explains how they have a weapon to take
down two nurses dragons the ancient
Targaryen would have had a weapon like
that too anyway so what he did is he
just found the research and said okay
they already have a version of this so
we're gonna build a bigger badder better
version that we're gonna use when
Daenerys comes marching on us we just
have to acknowledge how awesome balerion
the black dread skull is we haven't been
down here since I think season 1 when
Arya was poking around this was also
where she heard Varys and Illyrio
plotting to put Daenerys his brother on
the throne before he got his golden
crown from Khal Drogo before the events
the rest of the show unfolded but number
Ford's an heir so small Council argues
about what to do we learned that they're
going to send the Greyjoy's south and
use the Dornish to attack King's Landing
because Tyrion is perfectly predicted
how sir she's gonna try and manipulate
the realm against them we don't want to
go in with a foreign invading force and
we're going to take the true seat of
power in Westeros the rock that's where
we'll send the unsullied so it all seems
good but the problem is is now they're
dividing their army and they've since
lost
Greyjoy's in now we know that they have
a weapon to fight the dragons so they're
just trying to balance the scales a
little bit and show you that Daenerys
isn't going to be able to steamroll
everyone and I think part of that has to
do with the idea that Jon Snow needs her
Alliance just as much as she will
eventually need it too because they lost
all their ships so everybody on both
sides Cersei in tenaris will need as
much help as they can get but number
three Jon finally gets the Raven from
Samwell so now he's separately gotten
messages from Daenerys to come to
Dragonstone and bend the knee and from
Samwell saying that you need to go to
Dragonstone because they're dragonglass
there so there's really nothing else
that he can do and there were a couple
weird moments during his big council
here where he's trying to explain to
them why they need dragons stone like
they all love the idea that there's
dragonglass at Dragonstone
like even as dumb as they might be they
put two and two together o dragonglass
at Dragonstone that makes sense but even
the little bear does not want Jon Snow
to go to Dragonstone they referenced the
Mad King killing Rickard stark like I
said earlier they keep likening all
these events that are unfolding to
events that have happened before during
Robert's rebellion in back during
Aegon's conquest but I love sir Davos
his reaction to it all dragons what a
dragons have fire fires good for
fighting White Walkers she sounds really
charming with that horde of hers but
number two Littlefinger goes to Jon Snow
in the crypts while he's looking at Ned
Stark just trying to find the strength
to do what he knows he has to do and
makes his intentions known for what he's
going to be doing with Sansa I love your
sister like I love your mother I'm the
one that brought her your father's bones
and John just isn't having any of it but
I love the look that Littlefinger gives
Sansa as Jon is riding off for
Dragonstone you can just see the wheels
turning in his head like oh I have to
start moving faster and faster because
Sansa is sort of wising up to him Jon
Snow doesn't want to have anything to do
with them so the really cool thing we
have now is we're building towards an
Aria reunion so hopefully Littlefinger
will just go off the deep end do
something super crazy and you'll have a
stark sister team-up vs. Littlefinger in
the next couple of episodes but number
one of course that awesome Greyjoy
battle big action set piece of the
episode of course they're gonna smash
her fleet they just want to
show you how relentless Iran is and he's
actually way more evil in the books but
I love the way they make his ships look
so much bigger than Yara's it literally
rams them then they board the ship using
this giant kraken weapon and he starts
going at them with his huge ax with the
Greyjoy's sigil carved into it so who
knows where he found time to make all
these fine weapons but he is armed to
the teeth he has this crazy armor on and
just mows through the sand snakes so if
you hated the sand snakes this was
probably one of your favorite moments of
the episode but how about that reek
scene at the end they've been going on
and on about how he's becoming more and
more like his former self Theon again
he's slowly becoming whole
but Euron tries to twist his mind shake
his confidence and you start to remember
the ramsay sayings from the book reek it
rhymes with week as he jumps overboard
so now you're on has captured hilarious
and tyene sand and eora Greyjoy in
decimated Daenerys his fleet I don't
even think she was able to take down one
of your own ships but it was a great
action set piece way to end the episode
so I feel like the Greyjoy stuff was a
lot stronger in this episode then the
Daenerys Jon Snow stuff because that's
all just still set up for stuff that's
happening in future episodes so the big
twist with Daenerys and Jon Snow won't
happen till next week in the following
episodes so they're gonna be a couple
episodes like that where you have
storylines where it's just about
characters finding information and
deciding where to go next
before they actually do it in a future
episode so let me know what was your
guys favorite part of the episode and
what do you think is going to happen
when Daenerys meets with Jon Snow
there's gonna be so many jokes because
people have been waiting for this to
happen in the books for so long and even
though it's gonna be different the way
that it unfolds in the books the TV show
plot is still written in service to the
book plot with minor changes for
characters that are dead or alive and in
different places the thing I'm really
looking forward to next week though is
the way they react to the prophecy of
the prince or princess who was promised
it just sounds like something that Jon
Snow would scoff at like he doesn't
really think about prophecy he's mostly
thinking about the army of the Dead and
even Daenerys seems very skeptical about
it which i think is actually a pretty
natural reaction for the characters it'd
be weird if Melisandre rolled up and
they just bought everything
she said hook line & sinker so get hype
about Davos melisandre reunion next week
it's gonna be great
what's gonna happen next is is I'll post
my trailer video for episode 3 and then
I'll do a Q&A video on Tuesday just like
I did last week there's a couple more
comic-con videos that I'm doing but
leave all your bonus video requests in
the comments below
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner locum please private message me
on the back end of my channel so I can
get your contact details while you wait
for everything click here for the latest
trailer video that has footage for
episode 3 in it and you can click here
for all my other comic-con videos thank
you so much for watching everybody stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight